sony has revealed the next god of war  game in development for PlayStation 4  the next in the series will simply be  called god of war and not God of War for  and it focuses on an aged kratos and his  son Charlie the gameplay trailer debuted  sony's press conference shows the pair  hunting in a snow Laden forest and  eventually facing off against a massive  troll the gameplay demo also appeared to  showcase RPG elements such as knowledge  points and a Spartan rage timed ability  that became available during battle the  gameplay video also briefly shifted  control between Charlie and Kratos as  earlier leaks suggested the game will be  based on Norse mythology this time  around so get ready to smash some skulls  in Valhalla the release date has been  revealed at this stage